doch das sie gemeinsam durch die masse
das war die sd karte in seinem rucksack
willst du presse alter müssen wir
konzentriert herzlich zu diesen neuen
video leute haltet euch fest
we talk halte ich fest genau hier auf
unserer plattform auf youtube ist eine
sache passiert mit der ich in meinem
leben nicht mehr gerechnet hätte und
zwar eine gute folgewirkungen ein video
hochgeladen bei dem als ich zum ersten
mal gesehen habe mir wirklich kurz die
trainings gar nicht reden aber aber es
habe ich schon sehr schockiert und
rebecca mir das video keine game master
videos mehr das ende für immer
aufgeladen dass wir mal schauen ob es
tatsächlich geschafft hat sich von ihrer
game master sucht zu lösen als
allererstes werden wir kurzem blick
auskommen will
ich glaube ich krieg das für euch ist
ein ganz guter auflösung deswegen ist
wahrscheinlich wissen pixel kämpfte hier
gerade gemacht kennt ihr den moment wenn
wir einerseits ein heil kick verpasst
also ihr tretet ihr das ins gesicht aber
er denkt dabei auch nach oder seien
schockiert
es wird mit sehr hoher
wahrscheinlichkeit der unterhaltung
leute wir schauen direkt rein wie immer
geht wenn ihr einmal 551 aber einen
gutschein gewinnen wollt seid immer
unter den ersten 20 kommentare in meinem
video und jetzt starten wir müssen das
ding yaping leute dass sie in ihrem kopf
sich irgendwie so eine welt vorstellt
oder zumindest bei youtube diese welt
schauspieler in der so fiktive
charaktere wie der game master ihr
aufgaben stellen die sie dann lösen muss
ich muss sagen selbst noch den ganzen
videos die ich über rektorin gemacht
habe habe ich diese welt immer noch
nicht ganz durch drohungen aber schon
mal denkt sie jeder gamer seit der
aufgabe gestellt
und da ist vorbei für immer und er ist
weg also wir müssten doch schaffen
ich weiß natürlich wie aber keine ahnung
wir schaffen das ich bin mir sicher
jetzt stellt sich eine ganz spannende
frage heute und zwar warum otto becker
wing mit der game master serie auf ich
glaube das liegt nicht daran dass die
video ziemlich schlecht gepflegt wurden
aber so was ich könnte mir vorstellen
dass du weg als ich vielleicht
er hat im dreißigsten video von mir dann
irgendwann hat bei konter zu machen für
den anderen mich verarschen wieder habe
ich jetzt nicht mehr so viel zeit ich
muss ja mal 18 uhr an einer station sein
die das puzzle ergeben hat und ich habe
ja vermuteter verfügung king's cross
handelt also jeder sind jetzt auch
wieder ganz tief tief im rapid hall in
rebeccas verstrickung mit dem game
master drin also irgendwie gab es
wahrscheinlich vor diesem wir schon 30
andere videos wohl welche komplizierten
aufgaben zusammen gespielt haben und die
führen sie jetzt zu dem punkt wo sie den
gamer sie besiegen kann
ja also als nüchterner mensch kommt
nicht auf so was und ich habe mich auch
gefragt was meint ihr ist der game
master böse oder gut ganz viele von euch
meinten gut ist es ja das ist eine sehr
tiefschürfende frage also das ist eine
frage die hat wirklich schon fast
philosophische ausmaße denkt die der
game master ist böse sowas ist für die
frage jeder der älter als 6 ist wird
sich denken was soll der mist kg könnte
cancel green sein bruder king george kg
wer noch karten oder jack ac die einzige
option weg king's cross okay also die
ganze sache läuft wieder so ab leute ich
kann das natürlich nicht mit sicherheit
sagen ob ich habe teilweise bekkering so
das gefühl dass sie so diese game master
videos auch irgendwie immer mit urlaub
verbindet so also ich glaube jetzt ist
sie gerade in london zum beispiel ich
weiß nicht wo ich genau suchen soll nach
diesen kampf in face keine ahnung erst
mal vielleicht in der u bahn stationen
drin und dann draußen vielleicht scheint
mal wieder game master nicht gereicht
gamers da war ja nicht genug deswegen
hat sie sich noch irgendwie in anderen
fiktiven charaktere dazu ausgedacht da
ist pumpkin facebook raeter ich bin
mittlerweile 24
ich kann mir das einfach nicht geben so
ich kann ich kann mich nicht damit
auseinandersetzen was jetzt pumpkin face
sein soll
alle tausende von euch die mir jetzt
bislang immer geholfen haben
always der vfb also wir haben wir haben
auch unsere differenzen vielleicht so
manchmal mache ich mich vielleicht ein
bisschen lustig oder so aber wenn es
dann wirklich ums eingemachte geht wenn
es darum geht die menschheit zu schützen
vor dem game master dann wäre ich
natürlich einander seite also langsam
ich das gefühl das passt alles zusammen
ich werde jetzt mal schauen ob ich hier
eben jemanden findet der wipark en face
aus ich glaube das wird echt schwer volk
viele sind schwarzen weil leute ist
passt einfach alles zusammen
unfassbar die puzzleteile kommen
zusammen und ergeben ein schlüssiges
bild
rebecca hat natürlich sofort die
verknüpfung hergestellt und hat erkannt
dass die skelette hier an der wand und
die ganzen leute natürlich nicht wegen
halloween da sind nein die sind dabei
pumpkin face oder game master oder keine
ahnung über ein fiktiver charaktere aus
oder cars kopf da irgendwas macht das
könnte einfach auch mal sein dass die
regenmassen jeder zwischen es das kann
kann schon mal sein kann
da kannst du nicht einfach ausrufen
lassen also ich weiss es okay das würde
vielleicht ein bisschen die spannung im
video kaputt machen aber vorne an die
bühne gehen und sagen ja sucht jemand im
hintergrund ausrufen
am 5
ich muss irgendwie an seine tasche rand
also so macht diese handlungen sind sie
steht fünf zentimeter hinter ihm redet
lautstark asse laute veranstaltungen sie
muss laut reden damit man sie versteht
auch das kamera kapitalisieren ich weiß
nicht jährlich an die tasche ankommen
soll
ja wir hatten tasche direkt vor meinem
gesicht ist ich könnte einfach mit der
hand angehen aber ich weiß nicht wie ich
da ran komme
[Musik]
dreht sich so dass man boxen sind
das würde ich mir wünschen dass das war
wirklich geil so rebecca ding macht zu
den rucksack auf und es ist einfach
nicht das was mit ihrem freund oder
freundin abgesprochen was da drin sein
sollte sondern es einfach so brotdose
und ist aber die falsche person jetzt
sowohl merkt aber ich habe eine sd karte
na ja nichts bemerkt privatleute diese
distanz ist okay das ist fest was soll
ich machen will kommt an
okay ich war jetzt ein rucksack auf
minutenlang an diesem buch sacro werden
lautstark ein teenager ist hier auch
klar ich hab das schon mal gesagt leute
weil frank rost weg aber nicht dieselbe
sache
das ist wirklich youtube kasperletheater
also die die ganze dialoge sind wirklich
wie im kasperletheater
ich hab keinen bock public viewing ist
jetzt auf einmal an irgendeinem anderen
ort nachdem sie pumpkin fest die sd card
getötet ohne das ja was gemerkt hat ist
jetzt dabei gar den game master zu
konfrontieren ja also
doch das hier mal da sich die masse er
die leuchtenden maske auf
ich habe da eine sd-karte korrekt danke
dass du die verwaltung ja du ich habe
auch nicht so viel zeit ich muss weiter
die
[Musik]
im licht
[Gelächter]
es ist der game weiß auch nicht
eigentlich ein gegner ist es nicht
irgendwie bösewicht oder sowas der
verletzten werde schaden will
es gibt sogar das war die sd-karte in
meinem rucksack
vidzone presse alter müssen wir
konzentriert zwar die eigentlich nicht
gefunden habe ist ja gut ich habe es
verstanden ich muss mich kurz
konzentrieren okay weil kurz die backen
richtig ist die mission jetzt geschafft
ja ja die mission ist geschafft jetzt
lass mich in ruhe
auch nicht zu verfolgen ja nun geht er
kunden rennt er ist wirklich geil
das ist einfach so krank und spektakulär
wissen was ich meine
okay das ist jetzt der ultimative
bösewicht 40 videos und eineinhalb jahre
lang gekämpft hast er geht einfach so
halb
ohne euch hätte ich das nicht geschafft
ja ich würde sagen
mission geschafft leute wir haben die
mission geschafft steuer mac i wir haben
es geschafft wir zusammen haben es
geschafft okay das ist jetzt schon mit
dem game master das war es angeblich mit
dem game master videos bei rebecca bin
ich kann es mir ehrlich gesagt nicht
ganz vorstellen also lübecker ring und
game master sind in meinem kopf zwei
dinge die sind unzertrennlich das ist so
wie montana black und hausdurchsuchungen
ich bin sehr gespannt welche becker
bringt demnächst denn irgendeine andere
fantasiewelt abdriften wird oder ob es
das jetzt wirklich mal dazu gerne und in
die kommentare ich habe hier einfach ich
vorgeschlagen das video hier oben könnt
ihr einen kanal abonniert das ist
kostenlos und würde mich sehr
unterstützt mich sehr freuen wenn ich
das machen würde und ja wie gesagt
aktiviert die benachrichtung auf einem
handy und seiten mit den ersten 20 so
meint man sich auf einmal sind
gutscheine zu gewinnen für seine augen